guest spots from last week your mom's
house did not have a guest two bears one
cave was Bert and Kumon nanjani no Tom
whiskey Ginger had on Reggie Watts kill
Tony tonight is with Brian Simpson Dan
Soder was on stavy's world and flagrant
talked with drewski now there's a hole
in my pants but it was like in this area
you know like but who is none of you
guys are fat I'm not like a fat thing
that's kind of like you're not fat boy
you guys aren't in like you carry it
well a fat thing in what way like
explain like no let's dress what he just
said
I look 38.
I wait till we're on today
[Laughter]
yeah I'm sorry did you think you were
yeah you might as well say I'm thick
though yeah that's okay you can call
yourself I don't care it in the front
but I got that [ __ ] in the back that's
what he said power bottom let's go
this past weekend in theavonne talked
with young gravy Stavros was on The Joe
Rogan Experience we might be drunk out
on Natasha Leggero the Honeydew had on
Rich Voss Tom Papa was a guest in are
you garbage and the tiger belly